I give this to you.
I want you to have
this with my blessing.
In goes the mustard.
Oh yeah.
Bread's a bit like toilet
roll at the moment, isn't it?
It's like gold dust, you've
got to hunt the stuf down.
I was lucky enough to
get one of the cheapest
loaves I could find.
I almost got a sense that
these were the kind of loaves
that you tend to use in, in an
American style grilled cheese?
Yeah, absolutely.
It's got a reasonable
sugar content,
so it caramelises beautifully.
Look, grilled cheese isn't
supposed to be artsy.
This thing we're doing here,
this is like a freebie.
I'm only doing this just
to improve your life.
This thing is better
with a hangover,
it's better with cheap cheese.
You know how most great
artists want to leave something
for the future for posterity?
I give this to you.
I want you to have
this with my blessing.
And you can pass it
onto your children
in the fullness of time.
What sets it apart from a
sort of typical toasted cheese
sandwich?
Because I've had grilled cheese
when I've been to the States.
And there's something
almost a bit
disgusting about it, which
makes it so delicious.
It's all the things your body
wants, it's fat, it's salt,
it's dough, and it's all those
things pointing to one place.
But here we're going to
improve it even better.
So take your two slices of
bread and grab your mayonnaise.
Smear it on both
pieces of bread.
Heat up your pan.
Do I put any fat into the pan?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
No?
It's much more
exciting than that.
This is absolutely
the sandwich that can
cure anything, a broken heart.
Take a slice of bread, put it in
the pan, mayonnaise side down.
Mayonnaise down on
to the un-oiled pan.
Yep.
Now, carefully put
the cheese on top.
And put the second
piece of bread on top
of that, mayonaise side up.
Got you.
Good.
A bit of cheese overboard.
Doesn't matter, that's fine.
Move the sandwich around to sort
of pick up the leaky cheese.
So why mayonnaise on the
outside of the bread rather than
butter?
Basically, by using
mayonnaise what you're doing
is you're frying
the bread the same
as you would on a
regular grilled cheese.
But you're also having a kind
of lovely delicious flavoured
omelety thing to it as well.
I'm salivating
thinking about this.
Yeah?
Yeah, I told you,
change your life.
Flip it over and lick
any remaining mayonnaise
off your fingers.
Is this the classic
American style?
They always put their
mayonnaise on the outside?
They don't always,
but the good ones do.
And the cheese inside is
looking gooey and delicious.
Move the sandwich around in the
oils and fats and greasy bits.
so it picks up the last bits.
It's looking like
it might be done,
the cheese is beautifully
melted inside.
Put it onto a plate.
If you want to,
you can lift it out
and put it on to some kitchen
roll and dab the fat off it.
Oh no, goodness no, that
would be a waste, wouldn't it?
If you do, we cannot be friends.
That's it forever.
All over, man.
You are dead to me.
Oh, the cheese is
starting to ooze out now.
Oh, it's a good
feeling, isn't it?
Onto a plate.
- Oh my goodness.
The cheese is oozing out.
So good.
You could also think
of it like a steak.
So you need it to rest
for a little while
as well, just for all
the little bits inside it
to sort of become promiscuous,
as it were, and blend.
And also, it's too bloody hot
to put any of it in your mouth.
Knife straight through.
Look at that.
There it is.
Oh mate, that's just
a thing of beauty.
- Yeah?
Oh yeah.
This is one of the
sandwiches for one
of those many long evenings
we've got ahead of us.
Maybe feeling a little
bit blue about the months
ahead in isolation,
make one of these.
Somebody said the
other day that they
don't feel like keeping some
of their older wines anymore.
Life is too short to
put these things off.
I've got a bottle
of Cote du Rhone
I found at the bottom
of the wine cellar,
and I'm going to drink it
with a grilled cheese sandwich
next week.
We've got a little
time coming up
when we're going to have weird
and random ingredients coming
in, and quite a lot of time
spent in the kitchen, I hope.
And what's nice about
something like bechemel
is it's probably the
first thing you'd
learn at catering college.
It's absolutely the simplest and
most basic tool to play with.
Add some milk to the basic paste
and maybe some chicken stock
and you've got
premium chicken soup.
If you add meat stock to it
you've got a thick dark gravy.
We're actually going
to thicken some beer
to make the basis of the
sauce, which still have
a lot of cheese in it as well.
But you can then use to
make a Welsh rarebit, which
is a brilliant snack, a
really, really easy thing.
Quite a child pleaser, quite
a crowd pleaser as well.
Stick that slice of
bread in the toaster.
Just go ahead, not too dark.
A lump of butter
here about the size
of a tablespoon for a base.
Something like that?
No, smaller than that.
Little smaller, half that.
As that butter is melting,
add to it, roughly,
the same amount of flour.
Combine the two together.
I'm going to put a spot more
butter in mine actually.
More butter is not
going to hurt, is it?
What sort of smell are
you getting off yours?
Good.
Should I be adding more butter?
Mine is starting to
bubble up a little bit.
Nope, bubbling is good.
Important thing here is to
use a terrible, terrible chefy
term is to cook out the flour.
How long would you
cook out the flour for?
Until you get this kind
of biscuity smell, really.
I'm getting it now,
rich tea biscuits.
OK, so now open your beer.
This is all I had lying
around, Newcastle Brown.
Class act.
So it will easily bubble up
and then go incredibly lumpy.
So you add more beer and
keep stirring each time.
So why beer?
Why are we doing this
with beer and not milk
as I suspect people
would do normally.
Because beer and cheese is
an amazing and delicious
combination.
Mine's got like scrambled eggs.
That's OK, keeps stirring.
Is that more like it?
Yeah, that's great.
OK, stick a couple of
teaspoons, at least,
of English mustard in there.
I've got Dijon, is that OK?
Dijon will be absolutely fine.
Add a big shot of Worcester
sauce, topping your cheese.
The other thing
you can do that's
really, really good with it
is put it in baked potatoes.
So this time, you can also
add if you want to things
like Tabasco, black pepper.
You've got a kind
of glue now, yeah?
Now you taste it and
see what else it needs.
Mine needs more Worcester sauce.
I'm going to give
mine an Indian twist.
I can't recommend this
stuff highly enough.
I've always wanted to lay this
stuff out on grease proof paper
and let it go cold.
And you could slice
it into squares
the same as that really
bad American burger cheese.
Oh wow, this would be the
ultimate burger slice.
This Guinness - and I know it's
the middle of the afternoon,
but we're in lockdown, mate.
It's going to be done.
It's almost like
Christmas, isn't it?
Being in lockdown, minus
the seasonal cheer.
Good?
Oh yeah.
Let's mirror it on top.
Right to the edge, but thicker
and heavier in the middle.
Oh some of it seems to
have leaked onto my finger.
Oh no.
Mmm.
Shove it under your grill.
Oh, I think I have saved
it in the knick of time.
OK, I'm going to have to
show you a trade secret here.
Basically, you take a
knife, don't cut it,
just push down into the
cheese on the top like this.
No, like this.
Watch.
One, two, three.
And then one, two, three.
So you cross hatch
the top with grooves.
That gives you a place for
the extra Worcester sauce
to run in through
the cheesy cover.
Mmmm.
What do you think?
I think this is the
most beautiful thing.